what's up everyone Matthew encina here
back for another tutorial and in this
tutorial I'm gonna show you how I made
this image and I'm continuing my series
on how we make our thumbnails for the
future channel and I'm gonna try
something a little different here where
I'm doing more of a speed design so from
beginning to end you'll see every single
micro decision that I made and I'm gonna
show you guys my thought process through
it so I'm just gonna talk over it
narrate over it and hopefully give you
guys a couple of tips so that your
designs your frames are gonna look more
interesting more dynamic and more
impactful let's get into it
okay so when I first started my process
I started by watching the video that I
was making a thumbnail for and I was
listening pretty intently I'm listening
to what Chris is saying what the
discussion is about and I'm taking a
bunch of notes which you can see here
then after the video I kind of
highlighted the notes that I thought
were the most interesting and then I
started doing an image search so the
thing that stuck out the most for me was
the idea that clients sometimes will
dangle a carrot in front of you and your
goal is not to fall for that right
they'll tell you oh there's gonna be
more work I thought it's gonna be this
and that and so I just really thinking
about this idea about this person who is
on a ladder and is getting a carrot
dangled in front of them which I know we
are all used to so I think the key here
is that I wanted to find some good
images that help represent that I found
some cool images on the stock side of
people who are on this ladder who are
reaching up and are trying to reach for
something that they can't grab and I
wanted to paint that desperation a
little bit with the stock images
I found I found some cool ones you know
people climbing in the sky people
climbing in a room and I found a couple
of images of the carrot dangling so I
brought that all in and I started
experimenting combining the two images
doing some really quick cutouts to see
how these things might align if they
were in the same image I'll be honest at
first when I started dropping these in
it
it was tough I was finding that the
compositions weren't really working that
well and so I had tried many many
iterations as you're gonna see here I
tried several photos of the character
who's reaching up and combining that
with several different options for
somebody holding the stick or the carrot
dangling on the rope and I had to go
back to the stock side I had to search
some more because everything that I had
found I wasn't really happy with so I
went back I started searching for more
more options and then I started finding
these cool images like miniatures
miniature little figures that look
pretty cool and I thought oh I might be
interesting to make this a little bit
more playful because a lot of the photos
I had found our businessmen felt very
much like a stock image and I don't know
I I didn't like it and again as you'll
see here I tried a lot of versions I
started moving it around moving it left
moving it right and the thing that I
couldn't really get was the proportion
of the character to the carrot so I
started playing with making the carrot
field much bigger right and the idea was
that if this is a surreal collage so
things aren't meant to necessarily feel
realistic I wanted to exaggerate reality
so I was looking for more bigger carrots
to see if I could play with a giant
carrot and a tiny little character I
don't know that it wasn't even working
right so you can see kind of fumbling
around looking for image after image to
see if I can find
the right thing so I started doing more
searches on miniatures to see if I could
find something cool and then I found
this very cool photo is this character
he's sitting on a ladder it's already
kind of surreal and I thought it was
interesting because he's sitting on this
ladder and he has his little telescope
and he's kind of looking far away I
think it's a telescope you guys know but
he's looking far away so I wanted to
exaggerate this this is perfect because
he was a tiny little character he's
dressed up in kind of a Corky vintage
way which works well for the collage
style that I was going for and so now I
started really playing with the scales
at this tiny character and a giant
carrot and then I started thinking about
like well how do I make this more
surreal let me look for some backgrounds
that might make it feel like he's way up
in the sky so I pulled a couple of skies
and then now the character feels really
high up and the carrot feels really huge
like it's dangling from space so I
started adding little details as you saw
in last week's tutorial I started using
these paper textures to give it that
nice collage feeling and that little bit
of that patina warm tint on top of
everything so I took a paper layer that
I had found online and I multiplied it
on top of everything to give it that
nice texture then to give it a little
bit of depth I got the carrot layer and
then I added a little bit of a drop
shadow and I started messing with the
hue and the curve so that the orange on
that carrot really pops out and really
stands out then I was looking at other
details to make it feel again really
high a little surreal so I found these
cool images of these birds and I just
peppered them in and one thing that
you'll know about me is that I really
like pushing the contrasts so having one
really big element one like medium sized
element which is our character here and
then a bunch of tiny elements so that's
how I like to give my shots extreme
contrast so that they look visually
dynamic lastly I started playing with
type because you know I had all this
negative space in the frame and I wanted
to make sure that the concept was
crystal clear to you guys so I was
thinking that you know some people don't
understand the idea of a dingaling
carrot and the idea of a dangling carrot
is that there's going to be something
later if you do this for me now there's
going to be something for you late
so I started playing with this quote
that I hear from clients all the time or
used to hear from them well if you do
this for us now there's gonna be tons
and tons of work later which Aaron on
our roleplay video he was playing that
part of the client you know as I wanted
to capture that quote and I thought that
would be funny to include in here on the
composition I started playing with this
typeface knock out this is a new
typeface that we're using on the channel
I really like it I think it's based off
of old letterpress posters that were
made for boxing posters so it comes in
all kinds of cool weights from ultra
condensed all the way to something
that's very heavy and tracked out or
something there's a lot of thicker
rather so I started playing with this
quote there will be more work later and
I started playing with the different
sizes and weights which you can see here
and then I started playing with the
layers of where the birds exist where
everything else exists and how they all
stack up and that's pretty much it I was
pretty happy with where it ended up I
know it took me a lot of rounds to just
cycle through different types of
concepts different types of ideas but as
you see eventually I landed in a place
that I was pretty happy with and it's
you're not always gonna get it the first
time and that's alright so if there's a
couple things that you could remember
here when you guys are starting to build
your designs think about what is the
concept first what are you trying to
communicate and make that crystal clear
so that will be the root of the basis of
everything that you make so because I
had taken those notes and I knew clearly
what my concept was I had something
measurable to check against to see if
what I'm making is actually going to be
valuable and is going to communicate the
things I wanted to do that's step one
just identify the goal in the concept
and then from there that's why I started
exploring started exploring the how and
what now that I knew the why I was
exploring the how and what how can I
communicate this in a way that's going
to be impactful for you guys so that's
why I tried so many versions here
normally like in my last tutorial I
didn't show you all
the work-in-progress steps that I had
taken but in this one I wanted to unpack
that a little bit more so that's why I
did this speed design so that you could
see all the steps I took all the fumbles
it wasn't perfect I'm not perfect and
you could see all the decisions I made
from start to end and then towards the
end you'll see that I added all kinds of
little details playing with contrast
again if you haven't seen my dynamic
compositions video I'll add it as a link
here and in the description below but my
rule number one rule for making anything
dynamic is just to add a lot of contrast
and what I mean is mostly in the size
shape color and value so if I'm looking
for something very dynamic make
something very big first something
medium-sized and a bunch of tiny little
things and that usually creates a very
interesting rhythm and pattern in your
frames and in your designs and that's
pretty much it so hopefully this video
was helpful to you guys hopefully this
new style of tutorial is impactful I
wanted to try something different from
last week because last time I tried
showing you all the big steps this one I
just wanted to do the speed design so
that I could talk over it and go over my
thought process as you guys can see
every micro decision that I made on
screen let me know which style of
tutorial you prefer in the comments
section below and if you have any
questions ask in the comments and I will
do my best to answer them well I will
see you next time guys don't forget to
Like subscribe and hit the bell so that
you guys get notified whenever we
release new videos like this and if
you're interested in sharpening your
skills in image making and storytelling
and becoming a pro at Photoshop consider
taking my style frames course which I
will add a link in the description as
well alright guys that's it for me
hope you enjoyed this video now it's
time to get back to work